you may have noticed that andrew cuomo
is completely falling apart so there was
a bit of odd juxtaposition yesterday so
andrew cuomo over the last couple of
days was awarded an emmy
he's given a television emmy for his
massively incredible performance during
the cove pandemic which has ended with
the second highest death per million
ratio in america and currently the
highest hospitalization rate
in the nation after he wrote a book
about his amazing leadership
a bunch of hollywood celebrities stopped
by to talk about this because when we're
talking about health
the people who know the most are
obviously celebrities so here is
spike lee and ben stiller and the rest
of the crowd praising andrew cuomo
to my governor the governor empire state
andrew cuomo congratulations andrew on
your much deserved
founders award governor andrew cuomo you
are the man
what i was trying to think of that's
something that i could say to you
that would uh be funny and so i called
your brother chris
who could not understand why you were
getting an emmy since he's the one on
television in the darkest stage of the
pandemic
billy crystal your daily briefings live
from new york
gave us hope gave us clarity gave us the
truth and gave us something that we were
not getting from washington
leadership oh okay so um it's good all
the celebrities came out and
that same week like within 48 hours it
turns out that andrew cuomo not only was
was lying about how many coveted
patients had died in nursing homes
but that he was covering it up and he
was lying to his fellow democrats and
then
he did in one of his trademark press
conferences like this emmy award
award-winning press conferences right he
did one yesterday
in which he just lied blatantly but he
was very clear about lying
so i mean i guess there's that so here's
andrew cuomo talking about how honest he
was while he was lying
to be clear all the deaths
in the nursing homes and in the
hospitals
were always fully publicly and
accurately
reported the numbers were the numbers
always people did
request information beyond the place of
death
not just where they how many in a
nursing home not just how many in a
hospital
okay um so we were always honest except
for the fact that um we were lying and
by the way everybody on the right knew
he was lying since may
everybody this is well reported for well
now about what seven eight months
minimum nine months and now the media
are getting around to reporting all of
this
my my favorite part of this press
conference is where andrew cuomo says
that he accepts responsibility
for letting people think he did anything
wrong which is like the best apology
ever here is andrew cuomo
man this guy he is such a jerk and you
guys propped him up as a hero
let it be known for months and months
and months he was the hero the census
was the villain
desantis actually ran his state
correctly cuomo's run a state like a
garbage heap here is cuomo
man this guy the the balls on this guy
it's pretty incredible
you'd never knock down all these
conspiracy theories the political
conspiracy theories
because they generate 10 a day but we
should have done a better job
of providing as much information as we
could
as quickly as we could and
we should have done a better job on that
uh yes
and no excuses uh
i i accept responsibility
for that i accept responsibility
for letting people i think think i did
anything wrong whoops he
he what an incredible incredible dude by
the way he then went on and he said
deaths in nursing homes were inevitable
inevitable right this guy this guy who
praised himself for his leadership he's
like yep
i let the olds die and you know what it
was going to happen anyway so whatever
man
i got an emmy kovid did not get into the
nursing homes
by people coming from hospitals covert
got into the nursing homes
by staff walking into the nursing home
when we didn't even know we had covert
staff walking into a nursing home even
though they were asymptomatic
because the national experts all told us
you could only spread covet if you had
symptoms
and they were wrong okay so um there
there's only one problem with this
it's possible that covert was present in
those facilities earlier also you know
the way that you get rid of covid
by not having the patients be in contact
with other olds
in the in the nursing homes and then of
course uh
and andrew cuomo suggested that um if
those old people were gonna die they
were just gonna die anyway you know
that's just the way it's gonna work the
truth
is it was in the middle of a terrible
pandemic
the truth is covid attacks
senior citizens the truth is
with all we know people still die in
nursing homes
today people still die every day
we're testing the staff twice a week
there's no visitation
people still die okay yes how many would
be the question
people still die is not that you guys
you guys made that you guys made this
human being into your hero
that was you okay so here's the thing as
all this unspools
biden's crappy economic policies crappy
coveted policies crappy racial policies
andrew cuomo falls apart
the media are focused in on what matters
most donald trump
and they're not gonna let donald trump
go away they just won't now trump
probably doesn't want to go away
but here's the reality of the situation
donald trump is no longer president
he will not be relevant to the political
conversation for at least another couple
of years if he decides to launch
another campaign which frankly i don't
think he's going to do because if i were
him i'd be incredibly tired of this
wouldn't you
so trump is not the relevant political
figure at this point
where are the democrats putting their
chief focus that are putting their chief
focus exactly where you would think they
are putting their she focus
directly on donald trump so they are
going to continue to drag this out
house speaker nancy pelosi is now
pushing for the creation of a special
panel
to investigate the january 6th
insurrection at the capitol a day after
several lawmakers called for a
bipartisan commission and report
similar to the one drafted in response
to the september 11th 2001 terrorist
attacks
pelosi said now as always security is
the order of the day
the security of our country the security
of our capital which is the temple of
our democracy
the security of our members to protect
our security our security our security
our next step will be to establish an
outside independent 911 type commission
to investigate and report on the facts
and causes
relating to the january 6 2021 domestic
terrorist attack on the us capital
complex okay what do you think this is
what do you think like here's the thing
i have an idea let's say that you wanted
to do a full investigation of what
happened on january 6 and call witnesses
and everything
you could have done that you know and
then maybe after that you could have had
like an impeachment charge because
apparently you can now bring impeachment
after the person's out of office
and you could have done that or you
could even have done that investigation
between the house impeachment charge
and the senate vote but you didn't do
any of that stuff you rushed it forward
for political purposes
and then you got it off the table for
political purposes and now you just want
to keep this hanging around for
political purposes
for years on end so you can keep
pretending that donald trump is the most
relevant person to the political
conversation you're seeing this in the
media today by the way
well you know this is still trump's
party it's trump's party okay
here's the deal the party is always the
party of the prior president until
precisely the moment it isn't that is
the way that politics works
the democratic party was the party of
barack obama until it was the party of
hillary clinton in 2016
until it was the party of joe biden now
the republican party was the party of
george w bush
until it was the party of mitt romney
and so it was the party of donald trump
this is the way
presidential politics works there are a
lot of people today being like well it's
a trump cult because you see all these
people who are condemning republicans
for voting against trump in this
impeachment trial
no trump is just taken as a litmus for
republican solidarity it's that simple
when you ask republicans about how they
feel about trump even those who are
pretty uncomfortable with a lot of stuff
that trump did even many of those people
are not like you know what
i think what would be great for the
party is to completely divide it down
the middle on the question of trump
because he's out of office
sounds like a great plan here's the
reality democrats need
the looming specter of trump in order to
justify all the radicalism they are now
pursuing
in order to justify the fact they are
bad at their jobs and they are pursuing
radical policy
and again the media are addicted to this
stuff because the media's ratings go
down when they don't talk about trump
if if they talked about joe biden's
budget or how joe biden likes to toss a
log on the fire and that was all they
were covering do you think anybody would
click on politico
anybody would watch msnbc obviously not
obviously not so the democrats are going
to continue to push this stuff forward
and not just that they're going to push
forward more radical policy on the basis
of trump
we have a democratic representative
named jacobs and she came out and she
said you know what we need
we need a truth commission yes a truth
and reconciliation commission like south
africa this is what she told
the the most reliable of reliable
sources brian stelter we need a truth
and reconciliation commission in the
united states which is the most
orwellian garbage i've heard
in at least 37 seconds so here she is
representative sarah jacobs from
california calling for a truth
commission
you know a truth commission a lot of
people will think of south africa we've
used them in countries around the world
and basically what it is is it's uh
communities all the way up to the
national level
having conversations about both the
glory and the glory of our history and
what happened
both throughout the history of our
country and leading up to and on january
6th
so that we can come to a common
narrative moving forward of what we want
our country to be
yeah that this is all great it's all
great and all they have to do the
democrats just keep shouting trump
because orange man will remain
bad and he'll remain the focus and the
locus of the entire democratic universe
until such time as he is no longer
convenient for those purposes meanwhile
while you and the media are distracted
out here with trump this with this other
hand that is where they are pursuing
their radical policy making which again
is going to make the country worse in a
wide variety of ways but the media have
no interest
in that the misdirection is at hand the
democrats are engaging in it
every single day do not follow the
bouncing ball follow instead
the actual activity that is taking place
in the halls of government
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content